okay are you guys ready okay
hardware multimedia and hardware we've
always been looking at in every topic
software and hardware in the
relationship between the two but
multimedia and this these kinds of data
have a very interesting relationship
with Harman that's why we're gonna look
at it in kazigo so maybe make a
subheading or something like that
multimedia and its relationship to
hardware
here's what I mean Hardware over the
lust you know well actually since
forever competitive knowledge right
hi we're advances okay now hardware as
it gets better and it's always getting
better hardware advances both in
response to it and has a result of
multimedia advances let me try to
explain what I mean
multimedia advances do you remember in
that video we're looking at the history
of animation and he was talking about
one of the new technologies that got
introduced which we take for granted now
which made the production and animation
much quicker right do you ever wonder
what it was heõs it was scanning any the
particular name thing ever was sea rock
scene right which is about mechanically
transferring images making copies of the
duplicates of them right so there was a
hardware advance okay
and what it led to was advanced in the
multimedia right the pictures looked you
could need to make more than it could be
more advanced and so on right so a
hotter advanced took place and that
paved the way for multimedia advanced
okay we'll talk about some other
examples of this in a second but it also
works the other way as multimedia gets
more and more we want it to be better
we want new features and that kind of
thing it pushes hardware developers to
design their systems better so classic
example that is something like say
blu-ray blu-ray right and DVDs before
them right blu-rays our Hardware advance
yeah but I think where it came from was
the multimedia event right what kind of
multimedia is advancing what people
wanted movies on big TVs right well they
wanted it to look good on their big TVs
so they want a high-definition really
high quality sound they wanted all kinds
of special features so multimedia is
advancing but all of those advances
require more space
right lots a lots more space not just
hundreds of megabytes but but gigabytes
right so this events also pushed back
and made the hardware company say look
we need a new standard we need to be
able to cram more data into disks that
are you know the same size okay so let's
think about that was just one a couple
of basic examples let's think about the
processes you guys know the process is
very well and in particular the hardware
related to them and how they've advanced
okay so I'm you might like to put
together a sort of basic table for
yourself okay and the columns that you
want are the process okay the next one
how hardware is advanced
at the last one how multimedia has
advanced at the same time well as a
result now there's seven processes right
and you remember what they I've got the
module from the motive device for it but
I'm only going to look at five of them
you'll see why hopefully in a second
these five are the ones that relate most
okay so where do we stop what's usually
what we think of as the first process
okay
collecting okay now how does hardware
advance with regard to collecting
multimedia okay if you some examples
right I
the most obvious example that comes to
me is right in front of me okay I'm
collecting video data okay collecting
said then there's my multimedia form and
I'm collecting it number one in in high
definition so this is and number two I'm
collecting it in a very very small foot
in fact I'm not really using a video
camera I'm just using our phone right
cuz just built in okay so not only am I
got high quality okay which is actually
you know the video recording setup is
high quality right but also it's very
small form factor so the actual cameras
that you need to record quite decent
quality stuff and now so small there
with you all the time they're very very
portable so I what's the multimedia
that's sort of resulted from all of this
okay well you've got this high quality
video that everyone can take right so
high quality video
is now no longer the arena of the
professionals right
anyone can make their own high quality
video so it is common you can just be an
amateur have very very basic equipment
or at least basic according to today's
standards and produce some pretty good
stuff so there's how multimeters
advanced and you know people are even
making money off this kind of feel okay
let's move on that's how we get a
different person I'm gonna skip
organizing analyzing I don't think then
as relevant to multimedia as the illness
and the other processes we're gonna have
a look at okay so for instance storing
and retrieving now I just gave you an
example of this a second ago right so
blu-ray was one of my examples but it's
not the only one right for instance I'm
in the market for a new computer at the
moment I'm just looking at what deals
are out there okay what would you say is
an average size for a hard drive these
days
300 gigs yeah I actually think that's
probably this small and obviously gets
other basic models and they're like one
terabyte and if you want more you get
two terabytes okay now what's going on
here storing under tray me what we mean
is we've got really really large
capacities things are huge
hard drives now measure in the terabytes
and blu-ray actually you know DVDs are
4.7 gig and blu-rays up more than that
even more large capacities and so you've
also got not just this is primary
storage right we're talking about as
primary so you know things like a hard
drive it's also secondary storage though
sorry yeah I think I got them swapped
hard drives secondary storage primaries
actually ran
in the same way now a really basic
computer is what four gigs around it's
pretty pretty normal okay first computer
my family bought was called the
Commodore 64
you know the 64 stood what it stood for
64 not Meg's of RAM kilobytes of RAM 64
kilobytes of RAM we can do everything we
can play pretty cool video games it
actually okay so things have advanced
from there now look that old and yet the
computers that I was using when I was
your age with that much less a bit no
question this is how the hardware is
advancing what about multimedia has
forced or pushed that events okay now
that's interesting you say that longer
films um it wouldn't make sense if you
have lots of longer films that you would
have larger you need larger capacity
devices I'm gonna suggest on the whole
films are not really getting that much
longer right like what's the longest
film that you've been to three hours
maybe like a lot of the Rings extended
cut might be like three and a half hours
okay I actually used to have movies like
say um bend her right that they were
longer than that they even had an
intermission in the middle like
literally you're watching and then
suddenly it so it goes intermission and
you're meant to gap and go away right
and have a break okay so I don't think
in general movies are getting longer
what is it about movies that's requiring
larger capacities it's the quality
okay so let's be really specific here
we've got increased resolution so that's
a visual thing right
so for example we talk about HD you say
you know 720p right that's a measurement
for how I become news or maybe 1080p
okay
so increased resolution not just that
things they just look better they sound
better as well so you got things like
say surround sound now what is this
around sound mean it doesn't just mean
you've got one two speakers right it
means you can speak it all around you
and the idea is that they're actually
transmitting different things okay so
sometimes when there's a sound that's
meant to be the front you'll get hear it
up here and sound the back it goes the
different speakers okay so six you've
got different dollar going to different
speakers that data takes up space right
and then that's that's gonna go
somewhere right so you can see how the
multi medium is is is fueling the
capacity minutes and also goes you know
vice versa now that for example when I
was in year 12 I've bought a digital
camera and this is back in the days of
people
it wasn't very common I think there's
only there's only two or three people
migrated you had one right and I had to
buy a memory card to go it
it was 128 days do you know how much it
cost me I didn't weigh em it
because it cost me a hundred and sixty
dollars $160 so this is like a lot of
savings to me right hundred sixty bucks
but I wanted to 28 big cut now these
days we these things let me pull it off
these USB memory drivers are each for
gifts each for geeks
okay not only are they about a tenth of
the size of what I got but I think there
are only I don't know 10 or 15 bucks for
gigs now let's just do the map for gigs
compared to 128 Meg's how much more
space have you got it's 32 times bigger
just 132 times bigger costs roughly 1/6
or 1/8 of the cost okay so it's getting
bigger it's getting cheaper now what
does that let you do as this happens
right I can now go out and it's
realistic for me I can just shoot lots
and lots of video there's no problem
right
I'm not limited to my thing which you
can take look who I'm 30 seconds of
video I gotta go back to my computer and
upload it and then I can go and take
some more ok so you see how they sort of
feeding off each other that was that
loop that went well you know before ok
this story noventri me pick me another
process well gets it we will get to
processing let's go to infinity now what
advances have happened in in this
particular process do you think about it
we're probably thinking about internet
speed right okay so we're talking about
things like greater bandwidth
not just the fact that you can download
more and you can download faster right
but also argue you can do transmitting
and receiving in more ways Kanye you
don't have to be tied down to a desk how
else would you get these mobile phones I
mean even you guys are seeing laptops
right now you don't have to be cabled in
okay all right the first time I was
trying to set up a network at home I had
cables flying everywhere I was tripping
over everything and then a few years
later we're gonna first laptop which had
Wi-Fi built in we turned it on we
inflict a few switches and it's just
internet I'm looking to turn anything
this is really weird
okay of course you guys has you know
taken for granted so we have great
bandwidth we've got mobile internet and
we've also got Wi-Fi not only being
widespread but cheap
in fact now if you go in a lot of
shopping centers let me see I think
Castle Tallis now office free Center
wired Wi-Fi router silk Town Center if
it really can't be there yeah I've been
to kind of obviously I know Parramatta a
lot of McDonald's they'll offer free
Wi-Fi if you're nearby right there's
free okay so there's a hardware advance
where you're going to transmit you
receive you okay now how is multimedia
how is that advanced in response okay on
top of we've already mentioned some
before right all of these things okay if
everything's bigger you're gonna need
more bandwidth to download it
yeah I remember I taste the download
movie trailers I would I wouldn't sit
there and watch it over the course of
three minutes you know I get it start
downloading and then I'd go to sleep and
then tomorrow maybe it'll be finished or
maybe the day after
okay but now you don't just get high
quality things you get a on-demand video
or multimedia of all kinds really right
so things like say Spotify okay there
you got your audio and of course you
know you have YouTube's and your videos
and all that kind of thing
so you could take one demand you could
test streaming okay you can say people
are now realistically they're getting
video what we call over-the-air okay so
people have data plans and they're just
watching videos wherever they are
because they can write so there's a
multimedia advance that's fueled by this
and also vice versa okay
you've also got things like say not just
entertainment right but you got
teleconferencing except we don't really
call it teleconferencing anymore right
we call it FaceTime or Skype or whatever
right so this is also a means of
multimedia that's being fueled by this
and fueling it as well as people
increasing
use this okay all the networks are
getting clogged up and so there's
pressure on network providers to say
look we've got to move to off 3G we've
got to get to 4G LTE right these
advances are also happening in response
to more people using these kinds of
services okay okay let's trade the video
resuming I think someone said before
processing processing now this is a
really simple one
really what's the hardware events that's
happened with regard to this process
that's gonna come up with uh we mean
processing right what's the main piece
of hardware that deals our processing in
a computer it's called the CPU right so
what we've got cuz they've done yeah um
is increased computing power increased
computing now not only are things like
say clock speed increasing now we
measuring you know you get hurt not
megahertz clock speeds increasing you're
also getting more cores inside right so
you know until I five chord you or
whatever okay you've got more power in
there is a proverbial saying that now if
you got a phone in your pocket
you gotta find you're almost certainly I
can basically guarantee it has more
computing power just built into that
phone than the entire space ship that
got man on the moon Apollo whichever
water supply which was the first polymer
eleven they got on the moon right there
had very very diminutive systems that
are actually running the spacecraft
okay partly cuz they had to they have
lots of power restrictions but the fact
that we've just got this in our pockets
all the time is amazing okay now what
happens well this one's tricky
what multimedia advances have pushed
this and have been enabled by this I'd
say something like say not just the fact
you've got you know bigger resolution
apathy but you've got saying higher
fragrance
what's the framerate do you remember
this in video or animation frame a
refers to how many individual images you
see per second right and because they go
by so quickly they create the illusion
of movement yeah well if you've got lots
of images flying by you need a CPU
that's gonna be purchasing all those
images and getting them ready for
display okay higher frame rates things
like compression this guys were
transmitting and receiving as well right
but if you're going to compress a video
so they can be downloaded quickly if
it's compress the one end it's gotta be
decompressed on the other and that
requires computing power okay sir
compression and a little thing called
vector based animation which we're
actually going to look at a bit later so
I'm just gonna mention it now I will
deal with that in another lesson vector
based animation we're almost there
what's the lost process that we haven't
mentioned yet haha
I skipped organizing analyzing it is
display which is usually the last one
now I've left it till masks I think it's
the easiest how is displaying technology
changed over the last few years we
talked that something or any kind of
mentioned in French yeah we've got no
careful
I think the HTV is gonna be over here
what's the actual hardware that
corresponds to it happy to your TV's
I've been here TVs I was um I was
listening to my dad she wanted to buy
replacement TV and he was talking about
how he's walking down the corridor in
like me good guys or something and he
said you know you really need 50 inches
these days like any less it just ruins
the experience right I just kind of
smiled at him okay because fifty inches
how big is 50 inches it's look like this
being okay but it's pretty huge like you
got to sit back cuz otherwise if you're
close too close to it you sort of like
look where's the character going on the
screen because huge right 50 inches
isn't the biggest how what's the biggest
TV yeah 80 inch I've seen okay very very
incredible right with them I myself just
have a humble 32 inch in her not about
what people have asked where things were
things with them so what are you got yep
mark screens and increasingly larger
screens we've got things like retina
displays this pesky retina displays
right I don't know if you've got a
device that hasn't written in display on
it well when you go and say visit a
website that's you know low resolution
it looks all for don't blurry and that
kind of thing
so way talking about here is pixel
density pixel density is increasing
dramatically okay
and if pixel density is increasing
multimedia has to increase with it and
vice versa
we've also got when you go to the movies
if it's an action movie you don't just
get to see it on a flat screen well it
is a flat screen but you'll put on some
glasses and you'll see 3d right now 3d
as if you remember okay it's not really
3d it's double image and it's sending
two images to do for two different
knives now that takes up more data right
so that's why this Hydra advances in
multimedia to go with it
what last one we've actually mentioned
it already but we just haven't written
it up here okay display isn't just
visual there's other kinds of ways we
can display data such as audio right so
I suppose the advance he would be things
like surround sound
five point one which is five point one
then your front speaker made one right
two satellites at the front two
satellites at the back that's five and
the point one's like a simple foster you
get a deep sound okay now they're all
sending different things through okay
now Chiqui one what's the multimedia
reason that is push for all this why we
want all of this exactly right it's
usually because you just want a bed on
entertainment experience
and on top of that right we want things
to be as realistic as possible do you
see things like 3d video and surround
sound they're about realism right so we
want increased realism when we go see
these things
okay so there you go this five in the
seven processes I think the main ones
and that's a little bunch of examples of
how hardware advances and multi-millions
is sort of feed off each other